le chemin de la patrie à mèze
je serai
y a pas de doute
monsieur bébé
au japon
l'avis de fac tri de clémence desrochers
sur une musique de jacques fortier paris
en 1962 sur le premier disque de
l'artiste
presque soixante ans plus tard on
associe encore la chanson à l'histoire
du mouvement ouvrier
[Musique]
clémence michel bonsoir entendue jeudi
soir le vrai été intronisé au panthéon
des auteurs et compositeurs canadiens
lors de l'émission bonsoir bonsoir sur
les ondes d'ici télé j'ai été surpris de
l'avis de sa des années que j'ai c'est
sûr que c'est une très belle très belle
chanson c'est à dire ce que moi je
considère que c'est on fait peur que les
chefs dans sa vie mekter une de mes
réussites c'est la vie de sa batterie et
le parthénon je savais même pas que ça
existait montassar la pathologie on m'a
dit que c'était on m'emmène après comme
mon père alfred desrochers le poète
avait déjà été honoré
tempérant heureux hasard clémence de la
fac tri au musée est présenté à la villa
bagatelle de québec
l'exposition propose une rétrospective
de l'univers de clémence desrochers
documents d'archivés poèmes et dessins
témoignent du talent et de l'importance
de l'artiste voir ta vie racontée et
c'est très touchant
quand même temps battu dit tout ça et
tous ces faits il reste y est plus grand
goût à la vie mais j'aime et ce beaucoup
boire que on pourrait voir aussi m'aider
c'est qui on pouvait lire mes textes que
les gens et ici ils savent que c'est moi
qui écris que mes chansons ce sont des
poèmes et puis alors là on voit on voit
tout ce que j'ai créée voilà
en couleurs
kifa noir
tous
j'ai beaucoup aimé l'idée comme qu'on me
donne toute cette place ici cld et genel
radio canada québec